Trascrizione: Aurora Bronzi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Nella mia vita faccio il designer.
Disegno ogni cosa, e da cosa nasce cosa;
ma da piccolo, non immaginavo
che potesse diventare il mio lavoro.
Passavo ore a guardare il cielo.
Di giorno cercavo le forme delle nuvole,
e mi piaceva aspettare
le nuove forme che il vento stava creando.
Di notte invece, chiudendo gli occhi,
mi proiettavo in una dimensione
immaginaria, spaziale,
fatta di persone, animali fantastici,
satelliti, orbite, pianeti.
Una dimensione che somiglia
a quella che state vedendo anche voi.
Somiglia.
Perché ognuno di noi, qui,
può riconoscere una cosa diversa.
Chi di voi ha visto la spuma del mare?
O la bocca di un vulcano?
O la pupilla di un gatto?
Chi di voi ha riconosciuto la Luna?
E ha pensato di conoscerla
anche se non c’è mai stato.
Con il tempo, perciò,
ho maturato la mia personale opinione
che senza esperienza diretta
non si può conoscere veramente una cosa.
Ecco perché credo che il conoscere
sia più importante del riconoscere.
Nella comunicazione, infatti,
un brand è più importante di un logo.
Voi sapete cos’è un brand,
e cos’è un logo?
Il logo è il segno grafico
che rende “riconoscibile” un’azienda,
proprio come la fisionomia di una persona.
Il brand, invece, rappresenta
i valori identitari dell’azienda:
include il logo, e mira a costruire
una relazione autentica con le persone.
Proprio come facciamo
nelle nostre relazioni più o meno intime.
(Risate)
Con la diffusione di internet,
e l’uso dei social network,
il brand è rimbalzato
dall’affissione alla televisione,
per atterrare dentro l’oggetto
più intimo che abbiamo:
lo smartphone, la nostra scatola magica.
Lì abbiamo disponibilità di consultazione
24 ore al giorno su sette giorni.
Ci trasformiamo da consumatore a persona:
lì possiamo dialogare con un brand,
per la prima volta, in tempo reale.
E per la prima volta,
possiamo stabilire una relazione
autentica con le persone,
Oggi un brand, per comunicare,
deve parlare alle persone:
non più al consumatore, ma alle persone.
Un brand funziona
se ammette e chiede scusa,
se riconosce i propri errori,
se aderisce a valori che rispettino
la natura e le differenze.
In sintesi un brand, per funzionare,
deve essere più umano.
Vi è mai capitato
di ricordare una pubblicità
senza associarla a un logo?
Non so se avete presente
lo spot di un'automobile
che schivava le esplosioni
di vernice colorata:
quanti di voi ricordano con esattezza
quale fosse la marca?
Nessuno.
E se vi chiedessi di ricordare lo slogan:
"La potenza è nulla senza controllo",
quanti di voi ricordano la marca?
Lui è Carl Lewis,
nove volte campione olimpico,
chiamato "il figlio del vento".
In questo caso, alcuni di voi
hanno riconosciuto qual è la marca.
E se vi chiedessi, invece,
di immaginare una schiacciata a canestro.
di quale brand sto parlando?
Bene:
alcuni di voi hanno capito
che sto parlando di Michael Jordan.
Questo però dimostra come alcune aziende,
anche investendo importanti budget,
hanno problemi di comunicazione.
Per risolvere questo problema
abbiamo teorizzato, applicato,
sperimentato, modificato e scritto
la metodologia del "Dynamic Brand",
dove l’azienda,
pur mantenendo i propri valori,
è in continua connessione con le persone.
Si tratta di un nuovo modo di comunicare
che sostituisce la tradizionale
struttura gerarchica.
Con il Dynamic Brand,
cambia l’architettura organizzativa
della comunicazione.
Non esiste più lo schema verticale
composto da logo, corporate identity,
below the line, advertising,
video, spot, user experience, digital;
ma l’architettura della comunicazione
diventa realmente integrata.
Il "Dynamic Brand"
mette al centro i valori.
Visivamente, lavora
sul Sistema di Identità.
Il logo viene portato fuori,
deresponsabilizzato;
e funziona al pari
di tutti gli altri media
per dare vita ad una
comunicazione coerente.
In questo modo riusciamo, anche,
a ottimizzare il budget di investimento.
Il Dynamic Brand è qualcosa
che coinvolge, che rivoluziona!
Che fa veramente arrivare
i valori dell’azienda.
Lo vediamo ogni volta
che progettiamo con i nostri clienti.
Questo è quello che succede:
il centro, il cuore, sono i tuoi valori!
Sono i valori della tua azienda,
e di tutte le persone che insieme a te
concretizzano il tuo sogno!
Così disegnamo un sistema di identità
che non lavora più sullo spot
pubblicitario, sulla forma,
ma sul contenuto.
e ogni volta possiamo scegliere
con quali media, o tecnologie, esprimerlo.
È il motivo per cui l’identità dinamica
è riconoscibile anche in assenza di logo.
Ma quand’è che esiste l’identità?
L’identità esiste quando c’è la diversità.
Ad esempio, non c’è ombra senza luce.
E al contrario, non c’è luce senza ombra.
Senza il proprio opposto, anche la luce
sarebbe qualcosa di non percepito.
Pensiamo alla bellezza degli opposti:
il bianco e il nero.
Racchiudono tutte le infinite
sfumature di colore.
Proprio come una finestra
che si apre sul mondo.
Il contatto con le diversità
suggerisce l’evoluzione.
Quindi, più conosciamo
e più abbiamo una visione oggettiva
del mondo, di ciò che preferiamo,
di ciò che scegliamo.
In questo modo possiamo costruire
la nostra vera identità!
Vi è mai capitato, non so,
quando tornate da un viaggio,
non dico che siete diversi
ma vi sentite arricchiti?
C’è una sfumatura in voi
che grazie a quel nuovo paesaggio,
a quei nuovi sapori, a quei nuovi colori,
ai vostri nuovi occhi,
ha stimolato qualcosa, in voi,
che sembrava sopito!
Per questo l’identità è nella diversità.
Per questo un brand, o un personal brand,
hanno lo stesso principio.
La tua azienda, tu come persona,
quante sfumature hai?
Quante cose vorresti fare emergere,
e che non conosci?
Nella tua azienda,
quanti punti di vista ci sono
che non conosci e che ti piacerebbe avere?
Ecco cosa significa costruire
un universo visivo
che evolve, che interagisce,
che si confronta, che sceglie.
Un universo visivo capace di mutare
con il mutare del mondo, di tutti noi,
capace di scavalcare il presente
e proiettarsi nel futuro,
in cui, come vi raccontavo,
il conoscere vale di più.
Anche quando pensiamo
che il futuro sia lontano, come la Luna,
e ci rendiamo conto, invece
che il futuro è già tra noi,
come le persone.
The future you.
(Applausi)